und jetzt das heute journal mit kreisel
berichte und christian sievers
guten amt wir alle stehen jetzt vor drei
großen problemen erstens der winter
kommt zweitens in deutschland gibt es
immer noch viel zu viele menschen die
nicht geimpft sind und drittens auch die
geimpften können das virus übertragen
und verlieren mit der zeit ihren schutz
der virologe christian drosten sagt wir
haben keine pandemie der ungeimpften wir
haben eine pandemie der chef des robert
koch-instituts warnt heute es ist fünf
nach zwölf
wer vor einigen monaten noch meinte wenn
erst mal alle ein impfangebot haben dann
können wir zurück zum normalen leben
will heute an seine worte besser nicht
erinnert werden von 2g plus hat der
bundesgesundheitsminister heute
gesprochen also geimpft oder gelesen und
getestet britta spiekermann hat die
details
eigentlich ist jens spahn nur noch
geschäftsführend im amt eigentlich ein
auslaufendes modell doch die pandemie
die wieder mit voller wucht da ist sinkt
zu schnellem handeln
wir müssen jetzt alles tun alles
notwendige tun um diese dynamik zu
brechen sonst wird es für das ganze land
ein bitterer dezember und wer noch nicht
den ernst der lage verstanden hat für
den hat der chef des robert koch
instituts ein unmissverständliches bild
es ist fünf nach zwölf
das hier ist die aktuelle karte der
sieben tages inzidenz aus deutschland
sie sehen dass fast alle landkreise
tiefrot sind es ist die ein déjà vu
kostenlose bürger tests werden wieder
eingeführt schon ab morgen im zentrum
sollen bis mitte april vom bund zur
hälfte finanziert werden
auffrischimpfungen für alle nach sechs
monaten doch all das reiche nicht
deshalb wäre es aus meiner sicht aus
unserer sicht konsequent wenn wir
öffentliche veranstaltungen erstens nur
für geimpfte und genesene ermöglichen
und zweitens nur dann wenn diese
zusätzlich einen aktuellen test
verweisen zweig plus testen habe
priorität auch in altenheim und kliniken
statt einer impfpflicht für das personal
über diese frage diskutierten heute auch
und kontrovers vertreter der potenziell
neuen regierung einigkeit gibt es nicht
alle berufsgruppen vom
reinigungspersonal über die küche über
die pflege über ärzte hinaus wirklich in
den fokus zu nehmen und wahrscheinlich
werden wir dort eine berufsgruppe eine
spezifische in pflicht in den nächsten
wochen einführen müssen was wir im
moment nicht gebrauchen können dass die
wichtigen pflegekräfte die man ja
praktisch mit gold aufwiegen kann und
muss das da ist dazu führt dass
möglicherweise die dann nicht mehr für
die patientin patienten zur verfügung
stehen was alle vereint alte und neue
regierung die sorge war die lage auf den
intensivstationen
19 1552 intensivbetten sind belegt davon
14 6%
patienten bundesweit sind noch
2481 betten frei für tobit patienten
aber nur noch 957 wegen der besonderen
anforderungen die situation angespannt
auch weil inzwischen viele sonstige
operationen verschoben werden müssen
politische eile ist geboten bund und
länder beraten am kommenden donnerstag
über weitere schritte auch am donnerstag
soll der neue entwurf eines
infektionsschutzgesetzes der ampel
parteien vom bundestag beschlossen
werden
wer sich heute rot im kalender vermerkt
hatte letzter tag des uno-klimagipfels
muss umplanen
im grunde war klar dass sich das
offizielle ende verschieben würde das
muss kein schlechtes zeichen sein
es ist aber auch kein automatisch gut
ist rund 200 staaten ringen um jedes
wort um am ende kommt es auch auf jedes
wort an in der abschlusserklärung und
den flanierenden flankierenden
vereinbarungen es kommt auf jedes wort
an wenn es darum geht war glasgow ein
erfolg oder ist die welt dort
gescheitert wo wir aktuell stehen
berichtet diana zimmermann
noch einmal klar machen worum es geht
das wollten die aktivisten heute am
eigentlich letzten tag die rote linie
sind die 1,5 grad und mehr als diese
darf die welt sich nicht erwärmen soll
die klimakatastrophe noch vermieden
werden und auch boris johnson eigentlich
auf werbetour für die booster impfung
macht als gastgeber der klimakonferenz
nochmal druck das ist der moment sagt
euren verhandlungsteams wie wichtig es
ist sagt ihnen sie sollen die
überzeugung und den mut aufbringen sich
zu einigen und diese abschluss erklärung
zu unterschreiben
den ganzen tag und abend wurde
verhandelt um wenigstens die bisherigen
fortschritte zu sichern aber das
verlangt einstimmigkeit von fast 200
nationen der große durchbruch wird heute
nicht mehr kommen ziemlich fest steht
schon dass zum ersten mal überhaupt der
ausstieg aus den fossilen brennstoffen
festgeschrieben wird allerdings wurde
die formulierung im momentan
vorliegenden text abgeschwächt für
manche vor allem die von der klimakrise
jetzt schon am härtesten getroffenen
länder ist die rote linie längst
überschritten
manche von uns verplempern wertvolle
zeit indem sie noch einmal verhandeln
was längst beschlossen war für uns ist
das 1,5 grad ziel keine statistik es ist
eine frage von leben und tod
doch viele sehen kopf mehr als
ausgangspunkt für eine beschleunigung
der dinge wir bewegen uns in die
richtige richtung sind wir schnell genug
nein aber die wissenschaftler haben ja
auch nicht gesagt dass wir es bis zum
ende der konferenz geschafft haben
um das 15 grad ziel noch zu erreichen
müssten sich die nationen darauf
verständigen ihre klimaziele bis zum
nächsten jahr nachzubessern zu den
erfolgen könnte morgen erwarteten text
auch gehören dass ärmere nationen ab
2025 mehr geld bekommen um die folgen
von naturkatastrophen
auszugleichen immerhin haben die usa und
china überraschend verkündet gemeinsam
den ausstoß des treibhausgases methan zu
reduzieren und das war ja auch richtig
und gut und er hofft dass china jetzt
hier seine klimaschutz anstrengung noch
mal erhöht hat das brauchen wir auch um
bis 20.30 zu so starken behinderungen zu
kommen dass wir dann das 1 5 grad sie
wirklich tatsächlich noch in reichweite
halten während die verhandler die
kleinen schritte wertschätzen finden die
aktivisten alles viel zu langsam zu spät
sie haben die rote linie aus dem
konferenzzentrum getragen weg von der
politik raus in die welt
die deutsche klimaforscherin friedrich
otto hat den aktuellen berichts des
weltklimarates mitgeschrieben und wird
vom time magazin zu den 100
einflussreichsten personen dieses jahres
gezählt sie ist nachher bei gundula
gause zu gast im heute journal
update aber erstmal hier der
nachrichtenüberblick und das ist kein
sollten da schauen wir auf die
innenpolitik für die wahl eines neuen
cdu-chefs gibt es nun zwei offizielle
bewerber sowohl der außenpolitiker
röttgen als auch kanzleramtsminister
braun werfen ihren hut in den ring in
einem brief an die basis für brown für
ein klareres parteiprofil und mehr
geschlossenheit wird im plädiert für
einen kurs der mitte im falle seiner
wahl werde er die bundestags abgeordnete
franziska hoppermann zur
generalsekretärin machen noch erwartet
wird eine kandidatur von friedrich merz
nach druck aus der eu lässt die türkei
bestimmte migranten nicht mehr nach
belarus fliegen das verbot gilt für
menschen aus syrien dem irak und dem
jemen aus diesen ländern kommen die
meisten der migranten die belarus
gezielt in die eu schließt so der
vorwurf der eu die will am montag neue
sanktionen beschließen das kündigte
außenminister maß in der rheinischen
post an an der polnisch russischen
grenze harren mehr als 2000 migranten im
freien aus in der angespannten lage
haben belarus und russland ein
gemeinsames militärmanöver abgehalten
schauen wir noch mal auf die korona lage
die sich nicht nur in deutschland
zuspitzt deshalb gelten ab sonntag fast
ganz österreich tschechien und ungarn
als hochrisiko gebiete wer von dort nach
deutschland einreist und weder geimpft
noch genesen ist muss in quarantäne um
die infektionszahlen zu senken plant die
österreichische regierung jetzt einen
lock down für ungeimpfte
rund sieben wochen nach ihrem
hungerstreik haben sich zwei
klimaaktivisten mit olaf scholz
getroffen als spd kanzlerkandidat hatte
er ihnen ein öffentliches gespräch
versprochen wenn sie ihre aktion
abbrechen
beide kündigten störaktionen auf
autobahnen an sollte die neue
bundesregierung nicht deutlich mehr für
den klimaschutz tun bislang habe niemand
einen plan dagegen verwahrte sich scholz
gleichzeitig forderte er die aktivisten
auf konkrete vorschläge zu machen wie
viel etwas wirklich wert ist merkt man
häufig erst dann wenn man es verliert
das ist so auch bei grundrecht
vielleicht gerade bei grundrechten die
gut klingen die man gerne liest aber die
letztlich für viele erst mal abstrakt
bleiben bis sie plötzlich eingeschränkt
werden noch nie in der geschichte der
bundesrepublik ist das so massiv
geschehen wie zur abwehr der pandemie es
ist die stunde des
bundesverfassungsgerichts manche sagen
es wäre die stunde des
bundesverfassungsgerichts gewesen denn
aus karlsruhe hören wir dazu bislang
merkwürdig wenig ich spreche gleich mit
dem neuen gerichtspräsidenten der schon
etwas länger im amt ist aber bis heute
auf die offizielle feier dazu warten
musste auch das wegen corona saar
attacke
die kanzlerin ist gekommen und der
bundespräsident auch nach karlsruhe
seinetwegen stephan harbarth festakt zum
präsidentenwechsel am
bundesverfassungsgericht steht auf dem
programm darin wendet sich havertz
vorgänger dann direkt an ihn
ein unbestechlicher und überaus klarer
blick auf unser land und auf unser
gericht wie bei stefan hat mich immer
wieder sehr beeindruckt es ist sehr
beruhigend zu wissen dass das gericht
bei dir in so guten händen ist
stefan hatz weg hierhin an die spitze
der dritten gewalt war ein schneller und
ungewöhnlicher schon mit 15 jahren trat
er in die junge union ein studierte jura
legte herausragende examina ab verdiente
viel geld als wirtschaftsanwalt und ging
dann auch noch in die politik seinen
wahlkreis in baden württemberg gewann er
direkt und das dreimal in folge
mit diesem video machte stephan harper
2009 in seinem ersten bundestags
wahlkampf auf sich aufmerksam
umweltschutz die bewahrung der schöpfung
der erhalt der natürlichen
lebensgrundlagen
sind zentrale ziele unserer politik
gerade der klimaschutz ist eine wichtige
auch moralische verpflichtung gegenüber
den künftigen generationen
bodenständig leise effizient so hat man
ihn im bundestag war genau seine
ausgleichende art führte ihn weiter an
die spitze des bundesverfassungsgerichts
damit ist er der oberste hüter der
grundrechte die machtfülle des
bundesverfassungsgerichts ist beachtlich
kein bereich staatlichen handelns ist
der verfassungsgerichtlichen kontrolle
entzogen keine kategorie exekutiven
handelns kein gesetzgebungs aktg ein akt
der europäischen integration als stephan
harbarth vor mehr als einem jahr
präsident wurde war die pandemie gerade
ausgebrochen seitdem erlebt die
bundesrepublik die härtesten
grundrechtseingriffe in ihrer geschichte
geschlossene geschäfte und geschlossene
schulen
abstandsregeln und nächtliche
ausgangssperren und das
bundesverfassungsgericht unter
hamas-führung schreitet nicht ein bisher
jedenfalls nicht die großen
entscheidungen stehen noch aus
alle spitzen des staates also heute
dabei bei der feierlichen amtseinführung
des präsidenten eines anderen
verfassungsorgans des höchsten deutschen
gerichts stefan herr präsident guten
abend
guten abend herr sievers angesichts von
grundrechts einschränkungen wie es sie
in der geschichte der bundesrepublik so
noch nie gegeben hat ist das jetzt die
beste zeit
verfassungsgerichtspräsident zu sein
oder die denkbar schwierigste man hat
glaube ich am ende
sich nicht einfach eine zeit raus zu
suchen sondern man muss die zeit
akzeptieren in der man in verantwortung
gestellt ist und wenn sie sich etwa die
anfangsjahre der bundesrepublik
anschauen wie fragil die demokratie
damals war dann gab es auch andere
zeiten in denen es sehr sehr schwierig
öffentliche ämter auszuüben klar aber
als sie erfahren haben aber was ist da
alles geben sollte an maßnahmen an
regeln die er massiv eingriff in unsere
grundrechte häufig auf dem weg einer
bloßen verordnung also ohne dass sie vom
parlament kamen wie viele schlaflose
nächte hat ihn das bereitet
es hat mir keine schlaflosen nächte
bereitet mit schlaflosen nächten werden
die entscheidungen des
bundesverfassungsgerichts nicht besser
aber man spürt jeden tag die große
verantwortung die mit dem amt verbunden
ist das gilt nicht nur für den
präsidenten das gilt für alle
richterinnen und richter am
bundesverfassungsgericht und deshalb
haben wir uns der
unna fälle genauso wie wir das bei allen
anderen fällen auch tun mit großer
ernsthaftigkeit
angenommen wir machen uns viele gedanken
aber ich lege nicht nachts wach es gab
zigtausende von beschwerden vom
taxifahrer bis zur opernsänger dann beim
gericht gegenmaßnahmen der regierung in
der korona krise aber das gericht blieb
merkwürdig still bislang warum
das gericht blieb nicht still das
gericht hat über 700 entscheidungen
inzwischen getroffen das gericht schaut
sich jeden einzelfall sehr sorgfältig an
das gericht nimmt jede
verfassungsbeschwerde jeden antrag auf
erlass einer einstweiligen anordnung
sehr ernst es geht in der tat um massive
grundrechtseingriffe es geht aber auch
auf der anderen seite darum grundrechte
von großer bedeutung zu schützen nämlich
das grundrecht auf leben und das
grundrecht auf körperliche
unversehrtheit
grundrechte stehen häufig in einem
spannungsverhältnis dieses
spannungsverhältnis ist aufzulösen und
das macht die entscheidung am ende
häufig so schwierig das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat im übrigen
an einer reihe von stellen schon in
einem frühen stadium der pandemie
korrekturen vorgenommen
in den ersten wochen der pandemie gab es
in deutschland beispielsweise keine
demonstrationen das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat frühzeitig
klargemacht dass ein vollständiges
aussetzen von demonstrationen mit dem
grundgesetz nicht vereinbar wäre
kurz unterbrechen darf sie sagen sie
haben viel schon geleistet klar haben
sie eine sehr sehr schwere abwägung das
ist ja ihre aufgabe gehabt wenn man so
will trotzdem die ganz große wegweisende
entscheidung zu diesen eingriffen des
staates in unsere grundrechte die bleibt
der bislang aus jetzt liegt bei ihnen
auf dem tisch eine entscheidung in
sachen bundes notbremse diese bundes
notbremse die gibt es ja aktuell gar
nicht zumindest nicht mehr im moment
warum wird diese entscheidung trotzdem
wichtig bleiben oder anders gefragt
können wir alle erwarten wir
bundesbürgerinnen und bundesbürger das
ganz klar wird aus karlsruhe was der
staat darf und was nicht in sachen
wir haben die entscheidung zur bundes
notbremse jahr angekündigt bis zum 30
november das ist im vergleich zu vielen
anderen hauptsacheverfahren eine extrem
schnelle bearbeitung wir werden in diese
entscheidung entscheiden über ein
bestimmtes gesetz zu einem bestimmten
zeitpunkt das haben sie soeben erwähnt
und das ist auch völlig zutreffend das
bundesverfassungsgericht stellt aber ja
nicht apodiktisch fest ob ein
bestimmtes gesetz verfassungskonform ist
oder nicht oder in welchen teilen es ist
und welchen teilen nicht sondern das
bundesverfassungsgericht begründet seine
entscheidung sehr ausführlich das
bundesverfassungsgericht entwickelt
sogenannte maßstäbe um im grunde die
verfassung in einem bestimmten bereich
zu konkretisieren und deshalb geben die
begründung des bundesverfassungsgerichts
dann üblicherweise hinweise für folge
fragen die sich stellen werden etwa für
kommende pandemien oder für maßnahmen in
der gegenwärtigen pandemie für die
kommenden monate also da können wir
einiges erwarten wir sind gespannt sie
können natürlich details dieser
entscheidung jetzt hier im fernsehen
nicht vorwegnehmen das ist schon klar
herr arbeit es gibt
befangenheitsanträge rauch gegen sie
ganz persönlich es gab ein abendessen
mit mitgliedern der bundesregierung
sie sind direkt aus der
cdu-bundestagsfraktion ans gericht
gekommen was sagen sie denn denen die
glauben das ist merkels mann in
karlsruhe und damit letztlich das
gericht in frage stellen
ja ich glaube dafür hat der neue
präsident des bundesverfassungsgerichts
schon viel zu viel eigenständigkeit
bewiesen zu viele entscheidungen
aufgehoben wir entscheiden nicht nach
politischer opportunität wir entscheiden
nach rechtlichen maßstäben und genau so
haben dass auch meine vorgängerinnen und
vorgänger gemacht die aus der politik
kamen denken sie etwa an roman herzog
der zuvor minister und abgeordneter war
denken sie etwa an jutta limbach
es ist für das bundesverfassungsgericht
wichtig dass die unterschiedlichsten
beruflichen expertisen hier vertreten
sind im bundesverfassungsgericht gibt es
keine parteisoldaten sonst würde man
auch nicht ans bundesverfassungsgericht
gewählt die meisten personen die am
bundesverfassungsgericht sind übrigens
einstimmig gewählt worden das schaffen
sie nicht wenn sie als
exponent einer politischen richtung und
als eine art strammer parteisoldat
wahrgenommen werden der wert der
grundrechte habe ich vorhin schon gesagt
ist dann immer besonders klar wenn sie
unter die räder geraten es gibt jetzt
aktuell bei vielen in europa zweifel
inwieweit polen etwa noch ein
rechtsstaat ist mal ganz konkret an sie
gefragt nehmen sie das dortige das
polnische verfassungsgericht noch ernst
das polnische verfassungsgericht
entspricht nicht unseren maßstäben die
wir an einen verfassungsgericht
erstellen in polen geht es der
gegenwärtigen regierungspartei darum das
justizsystem fast lehrbuch artig zu
beschädigen die unabhängigkeit der
justiz zu beseitigen warum ist die
eigentlich so wichtig die ist deshalb so
wichtig damit eine regierung und ein
parlament effektiv kontrolliert werden
damit deren macht begrenzt wird davon
kann in polen keine rede mehr sein die
unabhängigkeit der justiz steht den
polen bestenfalls noch auf dem papier
sagt stephan harbarth der präsident des
bundesverfassungsgerichts heute
feierlich ins amt eingeführt herzlichen
dank für das gespräch
sehr gerne etwas
und das gespräch haben wir oft aus
termingründen am abend aufgezeichnet
jetzt noch mal kein server mit einem
zeichen dafür wie die fliegerei wieder
abheben es gab gute nachrichten von der
lufthansa wegen der korona krise musste
die fluglinie jahr mit milliardenhilfen
gestützt werden die hat sie dem
deutschen steuerzahler nun zurückgezahlt
sie tippte die letzte milliarde aus
einer sogenannten stillen einlage damit
verbleibt nur noch das aktienpaket mit
dem der staat gut 14 prozent an dem
unternehmen hält in den kommenden zwei
jahren soll auch das verkauft werden für
rohstoffe und vorprodukte müssen
unternehmen immer tiefer in die tasche
greifen die großhandelspreise lagen im
oktober um 15,2 prozent höher als im
vorjahresmonat besonders stark schlugen
mineralölprodukte zu buche
in der regel schlagen sich hohe händler
preise zeitverzögert auf die
verbraucherpreise nieder trotzdem sehen
wir an der börse wieder mal höhenflüge
frank bethmann wie passt das zusammen na
ja zunächst die inflation die wird ein
thema bleiben aber die unternehmen
verdienen derzeit trotzdem gutes geld
trotz der gestiegenen materialpreise die
auftragsbücher sind voll die
geschäftszahlen gut gestern siemens
heute die deutsche telekom dienen als
beleg dafür und der andere grund für den
stabilen aufwärtstrend auch den zuletzt
wenig geachtet wurde ist der
wiedererstarkte dollar eine währung ja
auch immer so ein bisschen so ein
gradmesser dafür wie stark eine
volkswirtschaft insgesamt unterwegs ist
und die konjunktur den usa die läuft
derzeit sehr gut wie genau wirkt der
starke dollar auf die deutsche
wirtschaft naja starker dollar heißt
schwache euro und tatsächlich während
der dollar so hoch notiert wie nie seit
anderthalb jahren hat sich der euro von
einem dollar 17 im oktober auf jetzt nur
noch einen dollar 14 verbilligt das
macht das geschäft erheblich leichter
denn mit einem billigeren euro werden
deutsche produkte in den usa günstiger
und damit attraktiver und das zusammen
billige euro volle auftragsbücher das
zählt im augenblick mehr als
beispielsweise kroner ängste die
spielten zuletzt hier keine so große
rolle drei neue rekordhochs markierte
der dax in dieser woche insgesamt aber
das muss man auch sagen gewann er im
wochenverlauf nur einen viertel
prozentpunkt
dazu danke frank an die frankfurter
börse
schon jetzt zeigen wir eine klasse
nämlich diese hier geöffnet sich nur für
wenige menschen heute durfte der
deutsche astronaut matthias maurer
hindurch schweben zusammen mit zwei
männern oder einer frau aus den usa nach
22 stunden flug war ihre space ex kapsel
an der internationalen raumstation
angedockt die neue crew soll ein halbes
jahr dort bleiben und dabei mehr als
hundert ex wissenschaftliche experimente
durchführen außerdem kommt auf maurer
ein außeneinsatz zu
die cdu hatte in den letzten drei jahren
drei verschiedene vorsitzende und sie
sucht schon wieder einen neuen wert
gerade darüber berichtet so eine
situation ist natürlich das aus für
jeden der eine künstlerische
langzeitbeobachtung plant welche spuren
macht hinterlässt im gesicht in der
körperhaltung
das ist die spezialität der fotografin
herlinde koelbl schauen sie mich mit
offenem blick an also direkt in die
kamera das ist die einzige anweisung als
modell ihr aktuelles beziehungsweise
vielmehr dass bei dem sie bereits seit
drei jahrzehnten auf spurensuche geht
heißt angela merkel
was macht die macht mit den mächtigen
mit merkel zum beispiel eine frage die
die fotografin herlinde koelbl seit
jahrzehnten umtreibt sie sucht die
spuren der verwandlung in den gesten und
gesichtern der mächtigen angela merkel
für sie von beginn an ein
außergewöhnliches politisches mittel
obwohl die unerfahren war oder
vielleicht auch ungelenk war aber sie
hatte bereits eine kraft in einer
eigenwilligkeit die mir aufgefallen ist
auch im vergleich zu anderen
30 jahre lang fotografiert herlinde
koelbl angela merkel niemand sonst darf
solange so nah mit der kamera an sie ran
eine besondere verbindung zwischen zwei
frauen
vielleicht fand ihr das auch interessant
dass jemand nicht nur mal schnell ein
foto macht sondern wirklich immer dran
bleibt und langen atem hat sowie ein
wissenschaftler experimente machen und
dann natürlich analysieren wollen was
ist an die mit mir passiert die
verwandlung der angela merkel sie wird
auch deshalb so eindringlich sichtbar
weil die jährlichen besuche der
fotografen im kanzleramt immer dem
gleichen ritual folgen
[Musik]
ich habe immer versucht sie möglichst
objektiv über die ganzen jahre zu
fotografieren deshalb immer ein weißer
hintergrund einen einfachen stuhl
keinerlei anweisungen damit wirklich das
eigene von angela merkel zum tragen
kommt sichtbar wer das eigene die essenz
der angela merkel was ist das eigentlich
herlinde koelbl jedenfalls bemerkt einen
entscheidenden unterschied zu all den
anderen politikern die sie über die
jahrzehnte abgelichtet hat angela merkel
hat es akzeptiert dass sie gefilmt und
fotografiert wird aber sie hat das nicht
gesucht oder geliebt dass er ein ganz
wesentlicher punkt bei ihr dass sie
nicht eitel ist
1994 erscheint merkel als kecke
nachwuchspolitikerin später werden
körperhaltung und mimik immer
kontrollierter die erste raute doch
plötzlich gegen ende ihrer karriere
macht sich merkel wieder locker dann gab
es einen moment 2018 ein moment hat sie
die hände in die hüfte gestellt und
gelacht und dass das ist ein bild was
man von ihr überhaupt nicht kennt und
was ich so wunderbar finde und wo dieses
diese lebendigkeit wieder durch geblitzt
es
der wesenskern so scheint es also blieb
angela merkel erhalten trotz der äußeren
verwandlung als gelungenes projekt würde
sie vielleicht die fotografische
dokumentation ihres lebens als
politikerin bescheiden bezeichnen
beitrag von peter theißen war das und
damit lassen wir sie in den freitagabend
zwischen ihnen einen angenehmen
ebensolche und sind jetzt gespannt auf
ein tier pieper und das neue zdf
politbarometer
willkommen zum politbarometer
corona ist angesichts täglich steigen
der infektionszahlen wieder das thema
für die deutschen im ranking der
wichtigsten themen dass das problem in
den vergangenen zwei wochen auf platz
eins hochgeschnellt vor den
themenkomplex klima umweltschutz die
unzufriedenheit mit den ergriffenen
schutzmaßnahmen ist ebenfalls rasant
gestiegen die aktuell geltenden coroner
regeln finden 16% übertrieben der
zustimmungswert gerade richtig ist stark
gesunken auf 32 prozent und 49 prozent
sagen jetzt die maßnahmen müssten härter
ausfallen das sind mehr als doppelt so
viele wie noch ende oktober
und die einhaltung sollte besser
kontrolliert werden meinen mehr als drei
viertel der deutschen
außerdem fordert eine deutliche mehrheit
eine impfpflicht für bestimmte
berufsgruppen
71 prozent der befragten befürworten
eine impfpflicht für beschäftigte im
gesundheitswesen und in der pflege 27
prozent sind dagegen
65 prozent sprechen sich dafür aus dass
lehrer und erzieherinnen sich gegen
korona impfen lassen müssen 32 prozent
sind das skeptisch
konkrete corona maßnahmen sollen nach
den plänen der ampel koalitionäre die
länder bestimmen innerhalb eines neuen
gesetzlichen rahmens bundesweit
einheitliche regelungen etwa für den
zugang zu restaurants und hotels sind
bisher nicht vorgesehen
sollte das bundesweit einschränkungen
für ungeimpfte geben eine zweig regelung
in restaurants im freizeit und
kulturbereich finde die klare mehrheit
von 67 prozent gut ein knappes drittel
der deutschen ist dagegen die anhänger
der fdp sehen dies besonders kritisch
für eine 3g regelung am arbeitsplatz
sprechen sich 71 prozent aus dann
müssten beschäftigte die nicht geimpft
oder genesen sind
arbeitgeber täglich einen cocoon attest
vorlegen
wir sind mitten in der vierten welle
aber die meisten befragten sprechen
keine partei besondere kompetenz beim
thema corona zu und nicht zuletzt wegen
des derzeitigen machtvakuum es vor dem
regierungswechsel
13 prozent der befragten sagen die spd
vertreter im ersten eine krone politik
in ihrem sinne bei der union sagen dass
25 prozent grüne 5 prozent fdp 6 prozent
auf 4 prozent linke 1 prozent knapp
jeder fünfte fühlt sich in sachen corona
von keiner partei gut vertreten und ein
viertel der befragten kann das gar nicht
beurteilen
die zuversicht dass die zukünftige
ampelkoalition einen wichtigen beitrag
zur lösung der probleme in deutschland
leisten wird ist etwas zurückgegangen
von 54% ende oktober auf jetzt 49
prozent kaum veränderungen gibt es
zurzeit in der projektion wenn am
nächsten sonntag wirklich bundestagswahl
wäre käme die spd auf 28 prozent plus 1
die cdu/csu 20 prozent grüne 16 prozent
fdp 13 minus 1 half die elf die linke 5
prozent
von den parteien zu den köpfen auch hier
gibt es nur wenig veränderung unsere top
ten der wichtigsten politiker nach
sympathie und leistung auf der skala von
plus fünf bis minus fünf
schlusslicht ist weiter armin laschet
minus 1,1 unverändert davor friedrich
merz minus 0,2 etwas schlechter auf rang
acht sie entspannen minus 0,1 etwas
besser
annalena baerbock 0,2 unverändert auf
platz 6 markus söder 0,6 verbessert
dafür christian lindner 0,9 schlechter
auf rang 4 robert habeck 15 etwas
schlechter vor ihm manuela schwesig 1,7
etwas besser näher an die spitze gerückt
olaf scholz 2,0 gestiegen weiter auf
platz eins angela merkel 2,5 etwas
besser
den weltklimagipfel in glasgow sahen im
vorfeld viele als letzte chance um die
erderwärmung zu begrenzen
zwei wochen lang haben die staaten in
glasgow verhandelt was wird nach ansicht
der deutschen erreicht wenig meine zwei
drittel der befragten 18 prozent sagen
sogar gar nichts kritik erntet nicht nur
die politik im eigenen land die deutsche
politik macht zu wenig für den
klimaschutz meinen 62 prozent der
deutschen in bezug auf unternehmen sehen
dass 67 prozent so auch die bürger
bekommen ein schlechtes zeugnis 69%
unternehmen nach ansicht der befragten
zu wenig um das klima zu schützen
was genau die nächste bundesregierung
zum klimaschutz beitragen wird ist teil
der koalitionsverhandlungen jeder selbst
kann aber auch heute schon damit
anfangen
das war unser bericht über die stimmung
im land die grafiken und alle
informationen zu unseren umfragen finden
sie wie immer ins zdf text ab seite 165
in der zdf- heute- app und auch zdf
heute.de wie die repräsentativen
umfragen der forschungsgruppe wahlen
zustande kommen informationen zur
methodik und zu den qualitätsstandards
finden sie unter politbarometer zdf de
vielen dank für ihr interesse das
nächste politbarometer gibt es in zwei
wochen am 26 november nach dem wetter
geht es hier weiter mit der heute show
in noch einen schönen abend auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guter abend und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter neue daten neuer rückblick auf
den vergangenen monate oktober und da
sehen wir über nordamerika vor allem
große temperaturabweichungen hier ist es
deutlich zu warm gewesen und auch über
sibirien damit es so derart zu warm wird
muss die wetterlage so sein dass immer
warme luft herangeführt wird deutlich
kühler über südeuropa teilweise viel
kühler als normal ja und das war der
drittwärmste oktober weltweit gesehen
einzig 2015 und 2019 waren wärmer
schauen wir auf das wetter und da
bekommen wir es mit diesem tief tun dass
überquert uns und bringt regen und das
schon in der kommenden nacht im westen
geht es los und das verlagert sich
südwärts ganz im süden dagegen gibt es
verbreitet nebel und er kann ziemlich
dicht sein bei tiefsten temperaturen von
minus 1 grad in der eifel und 7 grad
richtung niederrhein morgen am vormittag
dann viele wolken im westen und regen
der verlagert sich richtung meinen ganz
im süden gibt es etwas sonnenschein zum
nachmittag aber vermehrt wolken im süden
und hier regen also es ist ziemlich
dicht dicht wird es auch nach norden hin
seien aber trocken und das bei
temperaturen von bis zu 13 grad am
niederrhein und 6 grad im vogtland am
sonntag gibt es noch etwas regen im
süden deutschlands verabschiedet sich
allmählich bei sechs bis zwölf grad
mutter trocken ähnliche temperaturen und
dienstag etwas kühler damit ein schöner
abend